green caddie club ces mots n'ont plus de
secrets pour daoud et mohamed une fois
par semaine depuis plus de trois ans ces
deux garçons de 16 ans se rendent au
club de golf de villennes sur seine pour
apprendre la discipline j'adore golfe
surtout le practice et
toute la semaine j'y pense quand j'en
fais encore j'en fais pas comme tu tape
la balle au practice ça détend coach de
l'as où tu crois tu vois la balle partir
loin après même le jeu sur le parcours
ça me plaît
ah ouais elle est belle celle là
130 s'en va ça va les sports qui sont
connus sur le quartier on va pas se
mentir c'est plus voilà le le foot la
boxe tout au début c'était très très
difficile de le faire accepter sur le
quartier parce qu'il n'était pas qu'une
inconnue c'est plus pour les pour les
gens aisés pour les gens qui sont en
lice une chance qui leur a été donné par
l'association freq qui allie sport et
aide à la scolarité elle est accompagnée
par la fondation winehouse qui permet
aux enfants défavorisés de pouvoir
accéder à des activités extrascolaires
ça coûte cher et après on a vu qu'on ait
beaucoup chez moi on n'aurait pas à ma
mère elle aurait pu payer faire un sport
pour moi cher et des sports pour les
autres os mais comment avais pas du
golfe comme ça et monde y est ce un
sport cher magie mais j'ai eu la chance
d'avoir un mine a du coup que grâce à
cette occasion j'ai pu en faire il s'est
enlevé je serais pas là je tiens à le
remercier venir aussi jouer au golf 6
aussi
l'accompagnement à ce sport
être respectueux travail et la rigueur
ouais
j'allais à 100 vrai parce que corps je
la sens pas la balle c'est un qui sait
trop bien on le voit avec ce nouveau
gène maintenant les golfeurs qu'on a
c'est de ne pas leur fermer les portes
il faut qu'ils essayent ce sport et qui
soit ouvert pour eux c'est vrai que sans
la formation les parents ne pourront pas
payer la totalité de ce sport avec comme
exemple les célèbres bobby jones tiger
woods ou encore qu'albert tchaï daoud et
mohamed ne compte pas s'arrêter là
j'avais d'être pro et si possible au
dessus c'est d'aller le plus haut
possible peut-être devenir un jour c'est
une fierté d'avoir deux d'avoir mettre
des gènes qui sont là depuis trois ans
et demi dans le golfe et il les
accompagne et si une fierté pour nous
une quinzaine d'enfants sont aidés par
l'association sur la discipline du golfe
l'association ferait qu envisage
d'organiser plus de court par la suite
pour que les enfants puissent passer
leurs drapeaux équivalent du flocon pour
le ski et participer à des compétitions
dans les yvelines